- [Instructor] We're
going to talk about one of
the most significant
figures in Western history,
and that's Gaius Julius Caesar.
Now, what we'll see is,
his life really marks the
transition from official Roman
Republic to the Roman Empire.
And I say official Roman
Republic, because it's important
to keep in mind, even at
the time of Julius Caesar's
birth, at the beginning
of the 1st century BCE,
the Roman Republic already
looked something like an empire.
You might remember that
during the Punic Wars
they were able to take
over Carthage's possessions
in Africa, and in Spain, at the end of the
3rd Punic War, they were
also, and this wasn't part of
the Punic War, but they
were separately, in 146 BCE,
were also able to take over Greece.
So any state that has conquered
these people that have
different languages, cultures,
and they don't have the
same rights as a citizen of
that state, well, this is,
by most definitions, what
would constitute an empire.
But, during Julius Caesar's
birth and during his life,
Rome was still officially
a republic, and that's
referring more to its form of government;
you had a very powerful
Senate, you had these
Consuls who were elected
for these one-year terms,
and there were all of
these checks and balances.
As we'll see, his life,
especially the end of his life,
marks the transition to an
empire, in which there's
a Roman Emperor who
holds most of the power.
But let's go into the story, and there's
going to be a significant
cast of characters
here that I'm going to go into.
So by 60 BCE, Julius Caesar
is roughly 40 years old,
and he's already a significant
figure in the Republic.
He is born to a patrician
family, he rises up through
the ranks, he's charismatic
figure, and in 60,
he forms a triumvirate with
two other powerful figures
in Rome, so you have...
This is Julius Caesar, of
course, and he forms this
triumvirate, which later gets known
as the First Triumvirate, with Crassus,
who is the richest man in
Rome at the time and is
believed to be one of the
richest men in Roman history.
As you can see, Crassus
is a good bit older than
Julius Caesar, he's born
more than a decade before
Julius Caesar, and he
also forms this alliance
with Pompey, who is
also a little bit older
than Julius Caesar, and is a significant
military figure, a general,
in the Roman Republic.
And this First Triumvirate,
even though it wasn't
an official, it's an
official government group,
it allowed them to really
hold the power of the
Roman Republic, and to really
move and hold the power
within the Senate, this First Triumvirate.
And even though Julius
Caesar was a Patrician,
he was part of the nobility,
they had populist tendencies,
they wanted to do things for the people.
You could view them as, in certain ways,
progressive, they wanted
to do land redistribution,
versus the conservatives, who wanted to
hold the power in the aristocracy.
And so, this First Triumvirate is able
to use their influence
to put Julius Caesar
in as Consul for the year 59 BCE.
And, as I just mentioned at
the beginning of this video,
there are two Consuls, the
other one was a figure named
Bibulus, but Julius Caesar is
able to dominate the position,
and he's a very powerful
Consul, and he tries to put
all of these populous reforms into place.
So this is already starting
to cause a lot of tension
in the Senate between the
populus and the conservatives.
Now, after he's done his
one-year term, he becomes
Pro Consul, which you can
view as a military governor,
and he's given regions that border Gaul,
so he's given what would be
considered Southern France
right over here, border
with the Gallic tribes,
I guess you'd say, near the Italian Alps;
these are two of the regions, two of the
three regions, that he's given to govern.
And he uses his position
as military governor,
as Pro Consul, to expand
the territories into Gaul,
to take on these Gallic tribes.
Now the Gauls, or these Gallic tribes,
they're super fragmented,
there's many, many of them,
Plutarch says on the order of
300 of these Gallic tribes.
They were militarily,
fairly sophisticated,
they were, many historians
say, comparable to the Romans,
but it was their
fragmentation that allowed
Julius Caesar to go after them.
So over the course of his
governorship, of his position
as Pro Consul, you also
have the Gallic Wars,
and that's what I have
depicted here in red,
from 58 BCE to 52 BCE, and
they end here in Alesia,
where Julius Caesar's legions
are able to win decisively.
And that is the end, and he's able
to take all of this territory for Rome.
Now, while that was happening, in 53 BCE,
which is right over here,
in 53, yeah, this is 53 BCE,
Crassus, who you might
remember, was part of this
First Triumvirate, he is
off over here in the East
fighting the Parthians;
you might remember,
the Parthians, this is now
the Parthian-Persian Empire,
they're the successors
of the Seleucids or the
successor of Alexander the
Great, who was the successor
in Persia of the Achaemenid
Empire, and while
fighting the Parthians, he
is killed, Crassus is killed
while fighting the
Parthians, which breaks up
this First Triumvirate, and
then Pompey switches sides.
He switches sides over
to the conservative side.
So now, instead of being one
of Julius Caesar's allies,
he becomes one of his opponents.
And so Julius Caesar,
he's victorious, he's able
to conquer these powerful Gallic tribes.
Plutarch, according to him,
Julius Caesar's legions
fought on the order of
three million Gauls,
I don't know if those
numbers are exaggerations,
they sound like they might
be a little bit of one,
of which one million were killed and
one million were enslaved,
800 cities were destroyed,
300 tribes were overrun; and
those might be exaggerations,
they probably were, but
it tells you the scope
of what Julius Caesar did
when he took over Gaul.
So, he's already this very
charismatic figure, he was
Consul, but he's a controversial
figure in the Senate.
He has these more populist
tendencies, while there's
a lot of these
conservatives in the Senate.
The First Triumvirate breaks,
Pompey switched sides,
he's able to take over
Gaul, and so you can imagine
as he is now victorious,
the Senators are worried.
They're like, this guy,
if he comes back to Rome,
he might have too much
power, and he might have
too much power to do the
things that we, especially
the conservatives, don't want him to do.
This land redistribution, and
all of the things like that.
And so they tell him, in
50 BCE, so this is 50 BCE,
let me circle that, in
50 BCE they tell him
to leave his Pro Consul position,
disband his army, and return to Rome.
Now, Julius Caesar's thinking to himself,
wait, I just did all of this.
These people are afraid
of me, if I go without my
title, without my army, who
knows what they're gonna
do to me when I go back to Rome.
So he says, I either go back without
my armies, or I go with my armies.
And so, he decides to do the
latter, he takes his armies,
and he crosses the Rubicon River.
Now, crossing the Rubicon,
I'm gonna write this down,
Crossing the Rubicon, is now
a phrase that we have in our
culture that means you've gone
past the point of no return.
There's a famous quote
ascribed to Julius Caesar
once he crossed the Rubicon,
as the die has been cast,
it's the point of no return.
And this was a really big
deal, because it was illegal
for a governor general, a
Pro Consul, to take their
legions outside of
territories they governed,
and this wasn't just any
region, he was taking it
into the Italian peninsula,
he was taking it to Rome.
So this was very, very, very illegal.
So the Senators weren't happy about this,
so they said "Hey Pompey,
you have to go face
"your former ally, Julius Caesar."
Now Pompey doesn't know
that Julius Caesar only has
one legion, a legion is
about 4-5000 soldiers.
He's thinking surely if
Julius Caesar is crossing
the Rubicon, he must have
a trick up his sleeve,
he's already had, you
know, conquering Gaul,
he's established himself
as this significant
military figure, and so Pompey says,
you know, Senators, I'm
not gonna keep him from
going to Rome just yet, I'm
gonna go over to the East
into Greece where we can
build up our armies and
make sure we are prepared to retake Rome.
And so the Senators aren't
too happy about this,
but a good number of them
says, "Okay, well if you're
"gonna leave, we're gonna go with you."
And so, Julius Caesar is actually
able to, in 49 BCE, take Rome.
But this isn't the end, and
we will continue it in the
next video, because you, as I just said,
the power of Rome has
now moved over to Greece.
A good number of the powerful Senators,
you have Pompey and his
armies over in Greece,
Pompey controls significant
fractions of the navy,
and so a civil war has now
broken out in the Roman Republic.